[ELECTRONIC INTRO]
LAURA LING: You had a
pretty difficult childhood.
Tell me about it.
DAVID WANG: Yeah, I was a
pretty unhappy kid growing up.
I would be afraid
of going to school
because I would get bullied
pretty often, physically
and verbally.
They would call me like a
loser, stupid, skinny, small,
retarded.
So this was about when I was
five years old, right here.
I had just moved
to a new school,
and I had a hard time
assimilating and fitting in.
LAURA LING: Why were
kids bullying you?
DAVID WANG: Because
I was typically
one of the smallest kids and
the skinniest kid, the youngest
as well.
My legs were so skinny that
I had to wear braces on them
because my quads were so weak.
I was really insecure.
I just was a really shy kid.
I was not confident in myself.
LAURA LING: How often
would you get bullied?
DAVID WANG: Almost on
a daily occurrence.
There were a couple
really vivid incidents
that still are in my mind.
Once I was pulled back and
choked by a bully and strangled
and slammed to the ground.
And no one really helped me.
People around me were actually
laughing and ridiculing me.
LAURA LING: How did
that make you feel?
DAVID WANG: When you are
bullied, and you're put down,
you really feel helpless.
I decided to just
isolate myself.
I would lie in bed
at night, and I
would think about the knife
set downstairs in my kitchen.
And I would think OK, if
I just took these knives
and I, you know, cut myself,
I bet no one would care.
I didn't know how
to control my anger.
I didn't have an outlet at all.
I mean, one time I punched
a wall, broke my hand,
and that kind of was an
epiphany for me after that.
You know, I have
to start finding
a different kind of
outlet or else I'm
going to end up hurting myself.
LAURA LING: So what did you do?
DAVID WANG: So instead
of punching things,
I started working
out in my room.
I felt invigorated.
I felt really happy and focused.
I felt really just alive.
LAURA LING: And how
has this ritual fitness
changed your life?
DAVID WANG: So it
started with that,
working out in my
bedroom, but it was really
training in the gym that
I fell in love with it.
And I was actually
around other people,
so it wasn't like
me isolating myself.
When I go to the gym, I always
take at least 15 minutes
to just put in my
headphones and visualize
what I'm going to do that day.
If you're not focused, you're
just going through the motions,
and that's not going to
give you the best results.
LAURA LING: When you
look in the mirror now,
who is the person that you see?
DAVID WANG: I see a lot
more confident person.
I see someone who's
made a lot of progress,
and most of all I see
someone who is on a journey.
The gym is symbolic in my life.
It's just a haven for me.
It's given me my
closest friendships.
I could even say it's kind
of like a sanctuary for me,
because it's really
therapeutic for me to be there,
and I decided to
become a trainer
and inspire and
motivate other people,
and I just fell in love
with that, as well.
LAURA LING: What would you
say to that young person who
is being bullied and beaten up?
DAVID WANG: I think life
takes you on a course
that sometimes you just don't
know what's going to happen.
And I personally
never would have
thought I would be at USC,
having a passion for fitness
like I do right now.
It will make you
stronger, and that's
what I would say to
me 12-year-old self--
to just stay strong
and push through it.
You will be OK.
LAURA LING: Bullying
is something
that sadly too many
people face in life,
but I hope you were inspired
by David's story of strength
and determination.
To see more episodes of
rituals, please subscribe.
And you can watch another
story about a young dancer
whose discipline and
passion have allowed
her to live out her dream.
RIO ANDERSON: As a
student, each performance
matters so much, because
you just don't have as many.
And in the competitions, you
only have one chance on stage.
It's a lot of pressure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]